mary kay cabot she gets to witness this
up close and personal the browns beat
writer for cleveland.com and the
cleveland plain dealer kind enough to
join us mary kay
how surprised were you yesterday with
the result
you know maybe not surprised with the
loss i really thought that the browns
were going to lose this game
what i was surprised about was just the
comedy of
errors one after another beginning with
baker mayfield's interception on that
first drive
it just snowballed from there and they
couldn't get it together
what are the expectations for this
season
well you know i set the bar at nine and
seven and i think a lot of fans probably
uh you know would agree with me on that
i think you know i mean they
they've been just going over you know
losing season after losing season
it's time to start winning they've got
enough talent it's hard for me to look
out there and see
odell jarvis austin hooper jack conklin
miles garrett denzel ward
and not have them win nine games they
need a winning season
uh you know i probably set the bar a
little bit too high but that's where i
think it should be
yeah i i have them as a playoff team and
uh
maybe just getting in and i don't know
what the steelers are going to be like
and the bengals will be at least
competitive i mean this game on thursday
night this isn't a must-win situation
yet is it mary kay
on thursday for the browns you know i
don't want to say
must win i hate to uh to use that too
early i like to reserve that for when
you're just about to be
eliminated from playoff contention so i
don't want to say that at this point but
i mean the statistics bear it out if you
start out owen
ii uh it's it's really really a long
hard road
to make the playoffs i mean the
percentages are very very low also it's
a division game
you can't be letting the bengals come
into first energy stadium
even though there will only be 6 000
fans there you can't let
joe burrow come in here and beat baker
mayfield that can't happen
and you've already lost a divisional
game to the ravens and now you got the
bengals on thursday night
i i love to watch baker and odell
beckham
and i i thought that he actually asked
he he went to him too much last year he
was looking to him
he had 10 targets yesterday had three
catches but
what do you think that relationship is
like between those two when they step on
a football field
well it's got to get better i mean these
guys can't be going out there and only
completing
30 percent of their targets that cannot
happen
uh and i don't know exactly what the
solution is going to be
uh you know they're not always going to
run up against marcus peters and marlon
humphrey this was a really good defense
uh the one big huge takeaway from the
game yesterday was the fact that this is
a really great baltimore ravens team
they have gotten better
lamar jackson is a better passer than he
was last year and it's a very formidable
defense
so beckham's not always going to be
getting beat up by
humphrey and peters and those kind of
guys so i think they will get better
together and they
have to i think they need to be in
double-digit touchdowns together and if
they can be
it means playoffs is jarvis landry their
best wide receiver
right now yes you know jarvis and you
know
jarvis and baker they can connect now it
wasn't for a ton of yards it only was
for 60 yards yesterday but at least
those guys
somehow find a way to connect and i
think it's probably because maybe jarvis
is a little bit
more precise in his route running you
know odell has always been able to
freelance to do whatever he has to do
uh to get open and you know to shake
these guys off and to beat the double
teams
and that's just not really the kind of
offense this is
if we speak in a month what do you think
we're talking about
i think that we're talking about the
browns bouncing back
from this horrible horrendous opening
week loss
and gathering some victories and kind of
just staying in the thing
good to visit with you mary kay as
always we appreciate your time
sounds good thanks for having me mary
kay cabot she's the browns beat writer
for cleveland.com and uh the cleveland
plain dealer